No end
in sight as the
actor's strike in Hollywood nears a week.
This is the strike
that some estimate
could cost $4 billion or more.
One of the biggest fears for striking
actors is the potential
for studios
to basically wipe out their jobs
with A.I..
Is that fear reality or not?
Donnie O'Sullivan is OUTFRONT
This is where we started.
It's an automated solution
for cosmetic and aging work.
Doctor jobs
through some technological wizardry.
80 year
old Harrison Ford
looks exactly like 40 year
old Harrison Ford.
Do you understand how they did that?
Not completely.
In the latest Indiana Jones movie.
Harrison Ford is de-aged for a flashback
where he fights the Nazis.
It's not Photoshopped or anything.
It doesn't look that way.
Hollywood studios
are moving beyond
traditional visual effect technology
and embracing
artificial intelligence,
turning to companies like Mars.
What is Mars done for monsters?
Aliens, robots and zombies?
I think that's the best name
I've heard for a company. Thank you.
The latest Spider-Man
movie released in 2021
features villains like the Green Goblin
and Dr.
Otto Octavius characters
who haven't been seen in years.
So they took the villains from previous
versions of Spider-Man movies,
and they wanted to bring them
back in that moment
and when they originally performed
that character.
So without naming names,
we helped Marvel
do that on a certain character.
Mars says its De-Aging A.I.
technology knocks thousands of man hours
off the visual effects process,
but they say they aren't killing jobs.
The demand for visual effects
way outstrips the supply
but there are a finite
number of artists in the world
that are able to execute on that demand.
Edward is a banner pusher.
Mars has also built an air
dubbing tool
aiming to make awkward out of sync.
Voiceovers like these
had a thing of the past.
So he loves you and you're not crooked
so bad. Yes.
Mars uses deepfake technology
to reconstruct
an actor's
lips to match the dubbed audio.
They tried it out on me.
First we sent them this short clip
I shot in a CNN studio.
I've always been terrible
at speaking any language
other than English.
In fact,
I struggle with English sometimes.
With that, they were able to do this
dramatically.
Danny O'Sullivan
a correspondent of CNN Asia, who
continued probably in long audio,
a good long list that is very impressive.
But
neither Japanese mebut that's a good.
My lips look French.
I don't know who you are.
This technology can even
put other people's words in your mouth.
But what I do
have are a very particular set of skills.
If you let my daughter go
now, that'll be the end of it.
I will not look for you.
I will not pursue you
my fellow Irishman as well.
Lipton was built for the purpose
of allowing studios
to take content in their native tongue
and put that content across the globe
in a way
where it looks native to the viewer.
For its part,
Meyer says it is not in the business
of replacing actors.
It's technology
is meant to enhance performances,
not create them.
I think it's not a question
of the technology.
It's how you use it.
Look,
you and I could be hit by a bus tomorrow.
And that's it.
But my performances can go on and on
and on and on and on.
And outside of the understanding
that has been done with AI or deep fake,
there'll be nothing to tell you
that it's not me and and me alone.
Fears of how A.I.
will be used as party wise.
SAG-AFTRA The Actor's Union is on strike,
saying the studios
want to replace them
with artificial performances.
The movie studios are pushing
back on that claim.
Technology cannot replace an actor
full on, so you cannot go head to toe
and redo the entire face
and expect that to be photo real.
The technology
just isn't there right now.
Now, as it relates to writers,
I think
they can more easily be replaced by
artificial intelligence.
All right.
You ended on writers there.
Although, by the way, you and the French
I mean, I did
I hear you mention Japanese.
That was that was amazing.
All right.
You heard
you ended there
with a potential threat to writers.
This is serious.
I mean, chat
and they're worried about it
writing scripts.
I gave a prompt to chap
GPT with a picture on the wall
the other day, unnamed picture, and said,
write me a back story.
Be creative.
4 seconds later, it was damn good.
I couldn't believe it or so,
you know, script writers, obviously
a serious risk.
Is it there for actors, though,
as you heard?
Look,
I think everybody should be worried
about how this could transform
all of our jobs.
As you heard there, actors
are less risk right now than writers.
But there is a fear and you kind of heard
Tom Hanks mention us
and can also be used in
good creative ways
that essentially actors
could be replaced by these avatars
that you scan a person
and that they're then placed into movies.
But while we've
you know,
we've heard from the experts
is that in some time away,
but this technology is advancing
so, so quickly,
we could be having
a very different conversation
in six months.
Absolutely.
All right, Tony, thank you very much.
A fascinating piece.